welcome to this video FM dark true
d'oeuvres that new guy here wait no this
ready title players his interface is
chess at ICC for Android ya know is
playing on a tablet or something really
find it remarkable that people actually
managed to play em decently on a tablet
um night is 60 what am I doing here I
maybe just Queen d2 c5 okay okay that's
a very strange combination of moves a
six and then e cigs and so on our very
strange sounds a bit too negative I'm
just saying it's it's uncommon to
combine those rules but it isn't
terrible for black yeah so what is this
you're saying that you can simply take
that pawn off maybe up maybe he can um
so f 95
hmm tough okay but I don't want to again
play a normal game and then lose on time
like in the game before but nothing
happened the whole time and then all of
the sudden oops losses on time and okay
so got rid of this thing maybe Ruby one
threatening before before ice Knight
takes before us answered by a3 b2 wasn't
really hanging here because b7 also was
under fire but I thought it's still
interesting because of that before idea
ok so I have before now I'm not just not
sure if it does anything good ok let's
do it you can maybe take only 3 this is
kind of interesting nope
I'm not saying it was good it just said
it's interesting okay winning the space
here has to go back to be aged why is
there no okay um yeah my night on g 50 c
coming with f5 or something probably not
age six maybe i should probably cover
cover the e4 square somehow
maybe this unsure Bishop e3 also was
kind of interesting
okay if I go to e4 his f scott and five
so that's no good so here is he
threatening f5 so FG five okay I still
want to cover at age three yeah of
course that super committal move in
since the move that takes two seconds
okay let's go here Oh question is can he
somehow uz five for its pieces or not
like Bishop c 8 97 95 this is a
possibility
might be possible might be possible I
cannot really go with B 6 here and 97 m
my just about hold I probably have to go
with f4 somehow just one now to prepare
it may be here night each form
I need I want to go Bishop back and then
F form a position would be really really
attractive I can get it get it going see
the left for ok and here we will
probably trade stuff great stuff only
one
and its eyes for one sided position but
question is can you win really win with
white or not pretty much reduced to
peace sacrifices on on age 5 + f5 but at
least I have some kind of idea well
black has just nothing might still be a
draw though
so Jim can I don't think I can avoid the
Queen tried already we difficult to do
so let's go for the Kree trade but now
the time has somewhat leveled so it's
difficult to engineer p sacrifice
probably that that is weird why is he
going to be 6c allowing me all the way
to a 6 that's strange
time warning is a very weird night
adventure there
check I didn't even see that didn't see
that move coming
check I'm not sure what a butt is
probably draw check it's probably a draw
draw our third and you declined the draw
around a good repetition I probably
would have won our time maybe I should
have declining the draw there's maggot
maybe just didn't have time to accept it
oh that's a bit disappointing from this
this very nice position then he even put
that night on that via journey i bloomed
really wrong ok I can take that win
immediately this winds immediately
because yeah I will actually promote
that's pretty cute actually now I see
that Bishop a four and then be six will
promote the pawn huh it couldn't work I
mean why would you do that in the first
place but I didn't I really didn't
didn't think about it I thought about
the move but I was only thinking that
this is some somewhere possible I didn't
see that that have time to do to do this
that also wins yeah I also thought that
I should win with normal means and I do
of course this this this terrible game
by me he really must lose this game and
it was too much allowing all that stuff
ok TM I really didn't see that he s III
as an escape square that's a bit
embarrassing and now it's
now it's kind of kind of okay FM yeah
this is the draw I mean okay taking on
age five was probably a bit too much but
I simply didn't want to concede the draw
that simply okay thanks for watching